I define success through balance I think
when you have a good balances you know
your your career type aspirations and
then also your family situation is it's
also healthy in different section of
your life kind of speaking well of each
other that's what is really successful
I'm John boyega I'm an actor and I'm 23
so I got a call telling me to come in to
read in front of JJ Abrams and Nina gold
the casting director my first audition
was all over the place
oh gosh I hope they never revealed that
first audition I was so nervous and then
after that I was a religion to a while
those seven months of auditions and
training and back-to-back meetings at a
balance filming and you know secretly
going to these auditions but I can tell
nobody about which is interesting I
didn't really believe it would be
anything substantial until I got closer
to the location and then I thought to
myself maybe he's gonna tell me whether
or not I've received apart it went it
went well hence why I'm here I was about
13 14 when I was just kind of like oh
that people do this as a profession and
that's when I kicked by it research I
was to research how an axis could
possibly get paid for playing other
people then I knew as a hobby and I just
like to embark on a journey of training
and me and new people and then by myself
going up for professional auditions now
always gonna do it so it's not organic
when I found out about the reality of
the action industry which is 0.1 percent
of the interest industry that is working
I was just like you know what I'm just
gonna go for anyway
you only live once so that was a big
risk for me I think we're just in a
continuous cycle how do we get here we
were created from the beginning and
we're enjoying you know this it's a
moment in our in our lives and you know
despite the conflicts or things that
happen around the world it's a very very
unique generation in the sense that we
have some kind of hope for a better
future